timcast.com drag show protester
questioned by police after intentional
vandalism Cuts power to 40 000 North
Carolina residents police have yet to
name a suspect or announce a potential
motive so the first story is shootings
at Power substation cause North Carolina
outages holy crap I mean that's that's
really what they're saying two power
substations in North Carolina were
damaged by gunfire and was being
investigated as a criminal act causing
damage that could take days to appear
leaving tens of thousands of people
without electricity
a protester who was protesting the drag
events posted on Facebook the power is
out in Moore County and I know why Emily
Grace Rainier on Facebook on our
Facebook page according to the Daily
Beast around the same time she posted a
photo of the Sunrise Theater the venue
holding the sold out drag shows in the
caption God will not be mocked so police
apparently met with this woman she said
that she's sorry for wasting their time
and what she meant to say was that God
works in mysterious ways the implication
was more so that the power went out
because the Lord was angry not that they
had any information that right-wingers
were attacking a power substation which
sounds really stupid as it is much
conservatives being like I know how to
turn off the power in a single location
shut down the entire grid makes no sense
but what does matter is that many of
these and uh many leftist individuals
are outright asserting it is true or at
the very least they're pushing the idea
without Merit the police have even said
it's not the case they're posting on
Twitter the escalation is is happening
I'm not saying all this a as I mentioned
earlier in my other show to be a black
pill I'm just saying this is happening
and I often point out
when we were seeing these stories four
years ago where the left would accuse a
right winger of doing something I'm like
you realize it doesn't matter if it's
true they believe it anyway even when
you can prove it Covington kids Russia
gate hands up don't shoot they don't
care
so what happens in a situation like this
where not only now do we have escalation
not only now do we have you know Elon
Musk saying he's he's afraid he's going
to die you have the far left outright
saying right Wingers are shooting up
substations and acts of Terror
one thing I try to do is to when I it
when if and when I come into contact
with people that believe stuff like that
I try to have the same amount of
Amazement when they find out they're
wrong to to go to kind of empathize with
their amazement as they're realizing oh
it wasn't targeted and then I'm like
okay I I get it now and I feel what
you're feeling as opposed to be like you
idiot of course it wasn't targeted just
be there with them while they realize
that they were not seeing the truth at
the time that's what that's one you know
but they're jumping to conclusions it's
not a truth it's automatically
everything is is right wing it's it's
them it's the political opponents that
that kind of deranged lunacy is is
dangerous it's not you know an
individual who's critically thinking or
assessing information that's actually
you know the responsible adult thing to
do here is wait until we have evidence
now we're trying to weaponize everything
it could be a lunatic it could be a
crazy person it could not even be
politically motivated it could be just
some guy or some kid be like hey look at
what I could do you know just some
deranged individual who knows I got to
be honest it sounds more likely to be
climate change activists and and antifa
than a right winger who was upset with
one drag event you've got you've got
people like Greta tunberg how dare you
you know it's like they want to shut the
power off yeah they want to get rid of
oil they want to get rid of energy they
want to literally create human Calamity
style events that would devastate
Humanity kill millions of people all
because they don't like oil well let me
throw out a hypothetical what if in
protest to all these drag events the
right wing actually started to throw
paint on classic paintings that were
worth millions of dollars how would that
be covered
yeah I don't I don't think anyone's
happy about that to be honest like you
know they're getting mocked by everybody
the people doing that over the climate
change stuff the the guy who's funding a
ton of it is a massive well-known
Hollywood producer he's put like three
to four million dollars into the
organization that is actually doing this
there's it's pretty funny and I bring
that up because of the hypocrisy of
somebody who celebrates art as this big
Hollywood producer he he learned how to
weaponize autism and mental illness very
effectively and these these children you
know clearly show us that there is a
mental health crisis clearly believe
they have been so scared that the world
is ending but because we have
politicians like AOC that go on the
bully pulpit and like the world's going
to end in eight years again not even
quantifying real data not even going
after anything legitimate but just
making things up out of thin air just to
radicalize just to scare people and then
we have these effects of it which would
bring on more pain and suffering to
humanity than we could even imagine
which is crazy
but uh it's interesting to see who
finances a lot of this stuff it's
interesting to see the result of this
it's interesting to see the news
coverage of this because uh you know
they've been trying to push through a
lot of these lockdowns a lot of these
restrictions they're going to be testing
some of them out in the United Kingdom
for many years now they couldn't they
couldn't never do it but then you know
covet happened and now covet is surely
looking like it's going away so they
need something else to of course bring
on the trauma-based mind control I want
you guys to imagine something
John Brown's raid on the Harpers Ferry
Armory he made one critical error he let
a train leave
when John Brown and his crew rated the
army they basically took it they had it
information could not travel
but a train was passing through and they
knew what was going on but he let them
go the train I think made its way to
Baltimore I could be wrong with the
details but it basically got out
informed the authorities who then
quickly mustered their forces and then
headed to the Harper's Harpers Ferry to
stop this basically John Brown was
trying to cause like a slave Uprising or
something that effect and I'm just
thinking about this today's day and age
information is instant something happens
the Tweet goes out but I'm just thinking
about what it must have been like to sit
be on that train knowing you were the
only person carrying the message of this
attack and that if you don't make it in
five hours time or however long it took
two or three hours to the city to inform
law enforcement they would take this
city they would have it and that would
be the end of it it's a crazy it's a
crazy concept is this a metaphor for
Twitter files 2.0 no it's just it's just
understand how vastly different things
have become and how that's having an
impact on politics yeah used to be that
the you would try and prevent the truth
from getting out governments would spend
time subverting and putting people in
prison and things like that now it's
impossible the truth now the idea is to
put out so much fake information that
the truth Blends in and you can't tell
what's what and and this this isn't just
limited to politics right because I'm
obviously going to bring a culinary
angle to this but let me just it comes
to food too so many headlines people
read about food are wrong and then it
affects their dining choices for 10 to
20 years I've actually gone to the
extreme of saying that because of the
government headlines about eating
Seafood being a bad thing because of all
this hypothetical Mercury and pcbs which
actually nobody's ever died of mercury
poisoning we eat less Seafood instead we
eat more meat and chicken which is high
in omega-6 fatty acids which is the seed
oil issue which is your inflammation and
therefore people are dying at a younger
age because of that it happens in food
it happens in every single industry and
the people who perpetuate these lies
it's the mainstream media because yes
you're always going to have people on
the right or the left who are going to
go out there and tweet obviously
outrageous headlines but when it gets
picked up by the media and then
basically adds credibility to it and
then they go on with that lie well
that's when this social cohesion the
fabric starts to rip at the seams and
then we all believe the liar many of us
do so you're saying I should just eat
nothing but raw salmon you should use
much Seafood as you can six of the eight
leading causes of death in the United
States can be alleviated through the
healthy consumption of omega-3 fatty
acids mainly found in Seafood is there
any problem to overdoing scallops
scallops well you might be a little bit
higher in cholesterol but then just cut
back on something else see there's a
reason I love oysters and there's so
much propaganda against them oysters
oysters are vegan
well think about it they actually have a
negative effect on the environment
because they're filter feeders so they
clean the environment so they have a
negative effect right I mean in a good
way and then there's there's no
vertebrae they're not sentient in any
capacity they're basically vegetables
don't insult them that's this way stop
it which is why it's so they're
delicious we should be basically eating
more oysters the poor oysters
filter feeding yeah but I mean you can
clean entire estuaries just with oysters
alone if you took 100 oysters and put it
in a big fish tank full of dirty water
and then watch over the next day or so
that water will be clean and all of the
dirt you think well then it must be
going into the protein and the food that
I eat no it doesn't it actually goes
into the shell which is then calcified
and then you can use that shell ground
up as fertilizer or nutrients in soil
when you do some sort of organic farming
it's completely closed loop there's so
many solutions to the problems they say
that are out there that nobody wants to
consider there's a lot of conflicting
data when it comes to high cholesterol
we should talk about that in just a
little bit but but if we could just stay
on topic here just a little bit you made
a very no no no no no no you made a very
good point saying you know people hear
one thing and people jump to conclusions
without actually doing the the work to
you know towards understanding something
fully especially when it comes to diet I
think that's one of the most
misunderstood things when it comes to
our Mainline Society especially with the
Obesity crisis that we're all dealing
with right now and how people are
getting absolutely wrecked and destroyed
because of the disinformation and
because of the poison that's out there I
also think there's a lot of you know
just like we should be careful about
what we put into our bodies we should be
careful about what we put into our minds
and I think a lot of these people have
been so traumatized by the echo Chambers
by the by the what's the circles called
not family friendly Circles of of
thought that that happen on social media
that they've been so radicalized that
automatically something bad happens
they're going to point to their
political opposition as their main
reasonable force behind everything ill
and wrong in this world just like the
club Q shooting again that story went
away very quickly why isn't anyone
talking about it anymore when there was
a certain agenda behind it now that the
agenda has been questioned somewhat
automatically the stories just dropped
by the corporate media when they were
talking about this thing like it was the
end of the world come on there's a lot
of things to to really consider here and
a special question thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time